[Musique]
et
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro de vip
aujourd'hui je reçois un invité à la vie
extrêmement particulière il est ivre et
noir il vient de sortir deux livres de
mémoires il s'appelle gérard fauré
gérard fauré bonjour bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation sur le
partager sur le plateau de tv 78 vous
êtes là parce que vous avez écrit offrir
des livres de mémoires d'une
autobiographie
oui alors le premier s'appelle le
fournisseur des stars parle dealer du
tout paris voilà aux éditions nouveau
monde et le second qui vient de sortir
gérard fauré point de la codi l'heure du
tout paris la suite
alors je pense qu'on aura compris qui a
été votre activité
alors maintenant vous avez aussi je veux
ceci voilà vous avez payez votre dette à
la société comme on dit vous avez fait
dix huit ans de prison en france mais
voilà ailleurs aussi je crois ailleurs
aussi bas 14 en france et 4 un peu à
l'étranger d'accord donc là voilà vous
avez tourné une page est alors moi
j'aimerais bien faire connaissance avec
le petit gérard fauré quand il est né
parce qu'en fait vous êtes vous avez un
papa médecin français qui vit au maroc
qui est le médecin à douter du roi
mohamed 5 et une mère qui appartient à
une tribu berbère que vous dites voilà
une tribu réputé pour sa piraterie sa
sauvagerie
bon voila vous naissez et qu'est ce que
dit votre père est dit ce petit ce sera
un diable il a le regard mauvais ce sera
un diable regard très mauvais je crois
que là encore non moi je trouve parfois
non mais là parce qu'on va on va faire
attention aux autres j'aurais dit oui je
suis très gentil
voilà en bref et votre maman qu'est ce
qu'elle dit elle dit bah écoute tant
mieux parce que moi avec tes deux grands
mollasson deux fils elle parle de vous
freiner
je m'ennuie à mourir je serais ravi du
corps et après pour lui donner des coups
de cravache et me l'a donnée et elle
nous en a donné et notamment a dit à
l'ats votre père a dit alors pas avant
deux ans les coups de cravache voilà et
alors moi j'en ai conclu vous avez été
un gentil garçon finalement pas ce que
vous avez fait plaisir à votre père vous
avez fait ce qui vous avait dit fin ce
qu'ils avaient enjoint de dire que c'est
un mauvais garçon monfils voile avait
été et votre mère une femme distraire tu
vas me mets musée elle devait s'ennuyer
même a pas trop fait plaisir donner un
droit qu'il avait raison il a quand même
donné l'idée oui bien sûr mais il a
lâché la faire après il vous a mis entre
les mains de votre maman et occupera de
son éducation
bon bref vous avez été à gentil petit
garçon s'occuper d'eux des scandales de
gérer les risques et on a eu très tous
les jours il y avait un scandale alors
vous vous étiez un jeune enfant métisse
vous alliez à la communale avec les
autres vous étiez dans une école matinée
à l'école française de 4,16 vallat début
c'était sa fille la ville où galabru et
mais très bien qu'à côté de ça ira
qu'est ce que vous avez comme chouettes
copains entre vous et vous étiez un
petit peu entre deux entre deux chaises
non en fait le problème était que
j'étais trop basanée pour eux lorsque
mes deux frères il y en a qui a fini
consul de france en espagne et l'autre
il était artiste peintre tout ça c'était
des bons petits gaulois ils avaient des
bonnes petites têtes de france et moi
j'avais une tête de samaras capcom
gilles de méthodes de quoi et
on me taquinait sans arrêt alors moi qui
ai marqué et moi je tapais alors à vous
passer ma journée alcala à la sortie de
l'école j'en attendais trois ou quatre
les duels lui sinon vous auriez été le
bouc émissaire à benghazi
j'aimerais vous tapez le nom des gens
neiger mais j'ai vécu l'enfer
l'enfer est plus salée plus devenez
méchant jeu devenait agressif avant lui
et maladresses ah oui
la censure est né au plus simple que moi
attaque c'est à dire à l'époque c'était
un peu les juifs on allait faire des
expéditions punitives
aujourd'hui je regrette ce que j'ai fait
c'est sûr c'était pas gentil par
oculaire que vous quoi ben voilà c'est
ça et les homosexuels alors menacé lui
taper dessus avec ma petite bande à
rabelais de berbères en équipe et vous
ayez tout de suite choisi le mauvais
camp entre vieilles malles vous avez
choisi un bel moi c'était bon quand le
poc voilà celui qui vous que vous
rassurer entre kiel et par la suite avec
ma petite bande on était sept ou huit en
jeter des cailloux on battait tous ont
frappé des petites pensées des p'tits
blonds aux yeux bleus là qui sera
racontée qui se croyaient plus français
que moi mais avec qui j'avais des noms
un peu à la peau noire
ce qui m'importe il venait non mais
venez de ne sait même pas des français
moi j'ai cédé 107 ce sont des dd
méchanceté d'enfants et mais c est s
était à l'époque de des colonies oui
faisait briller sans si les gens
d'europe centrale de partout on leur
donnait le passeport français j'étais
français mais il était encore plus
français que français n'accordent plus
royaliste que le roi vous qui venaient
de gaza et avec cause de paris il était
plus royaliste que le roi
savez vous avez une vie très longue et
très remplie qui n'est pas terminé
d'ailleurs leur appréciation c'est ce
que sinon on en a plein les yeux aux
américains donc après mais vous trouvez
cette activité finalement très lucrative
dans laquelle vous excellez à savoir
10h02 coup pouce est réputé je n'ai pas
fait ça je sais que n'avait pas fait que
ça mais là c'est un peu ce dont on parle
aujourd'hui avec ce livre
et finalement vous trouvé confronté à
des milieux hallucinant on peut dire ça
alors oui c'est très étonnant tout ce
qu'on lit dans votre livre tout ce que
vous révéler oui non mais c'est parce
que le commun des mortels pour nous qui
avons des vies simples et ranger c'est
que même on tombe de l'armoire
oui certainement bande mais moi j'ai
vécu la décolonisation encore donc
évidemment de d'algérie nous est venue
lowe s étaient pas des petits cadeaux et
du maroc c'est pareil les jmf quitté le
maroc beaucoup de français partent et
tout est beaucoup beaucoup de français
sont devenus voyous parce que bon
il voulait pas rentrer en france ils
savaient pas ils connaissaient pas la
france où on était un peu un peu dépaysé
ne savait pas on savait pas où on y va
il manquait les codes coiffe et ses
racines et vous arriviez en a en temps
en espagne et c'est l'espagne était à
cette époque dans les années 65
le lieu de rendez-vous 63 quand tout le
monde est parti d'algérie d'accord
c'était le lieu de rendez vous des
français un peu déphasé faisait mal et
s'imagine alizés de faire marginaliser
des racines je comprends alors on va
arriver dans les années 80 c'est un
petit peu entre guillemets l'heure pas
de gloire mais les bonnes années pour
vous ah oui on est d'accord
oui alors si les gens veulent savoir de
qui on parle il ya tout un tas de gens
connus qui sont malheureusement décédés
certain que vous aviez prévenu
d'ailleurs des méfaits de la cocaïne
tout à fait certain vous leur avez dit
attention s'il était mineure
on se sent voilà c'est à dire que
l'offre à savoir que ça donne des
cancers oui c'était le côté de mon père
qui est ressorti des défenseurs côté
médecins côté de voile a fait attention
quand même n'exagère pas et ça ça a
continué toute ma vie j'ai toujours fait
attention et préserver mes clients oui
ils ont pas fait pas ça fait pas ça ils
l'ont fait quand même à eelv on fait
comme ils l'ont payé dans ma vie en
somme on évite avec plusieurs cancers
donc tout ça c'est dans le dans ce
fameux livre ensuite il ya un autre truc
qui m'a qui m'a fait aussi tombé de
l'armoire si je puis dire étonné c'est
quand vous écrivez que vous avez monté
une maison d'after alors une after c'est
fois mais je sais ça avec aero radio
quelle drôle d'idée d'aller à versailles
pour un truc pareil parce que d'une
after c'est quoi c'est après les bois
après être allé en boîte on n'a pas
envie d'aller se coucher que ce serait
sa position ou même quand on envie de de
s'amuser avec son petit ami comme le
faisait diony ben on va dans un endroit
bien
disque vous voit discret puis à la
cocaïne à gogo pour moi c'est le paradis
alors pourquoi va remonter ça versailles
tout de même alors justement parce que
mon beau-père donc bernard noël habilité
au 32 boulevard assez s'amuse l'ancien
ambassadeur de france au vatican et
journaliste attitré du vatican
tout ça pour ça dans mon top 2 je parle
de ça il me raconte tout ce qui ce oui
alors dans le tome 2 vous avez
approfondie certains points il ya
notamment une mannequin vous dites
célèbre des nations à faire une vidéo
très bientôt
ah oui demande à savoir ça c'était un
petit peu le coup de trop qui vous a
fait arrêter aussi je pense mais enfin
revenant à versailles alors donc c'est
les maisons de facebook est là ce qu'il
m'a fait arrêter
oui donc je vous dis donc bernard noël
un jour vient me rendre visite en prison
à amsterdam avec ma mère et ma mère me
dit gérard surtout ne dit pas quels à
pois drogue mais lui il savait son père
avait été le chef de la police française
mini ce plénipotentiaire du général de
gaulle tout ça donc il savait déjà mais
il faisait semblant et fusées l'imbécile
et puis après une grille banques quand
tu sors de prison tue passent nous voir
adversaires mais oui avec plaisir je
passe à versailles il dit rapidement b
mais zinedine oui bon tu m'as pris pour
un con gimont nombre une dit je sais
très bien que rapporte qu'il dit est ce
que tu en as junior et la voulez vous
une bille brown mois djigui comment ça
se fait obligé après au vatican après
dans la tuerie ouais ouais c'est vrai je
le mets dans le stum de dangy abri là il
commence à me relaté un peu comment ça
se passait au vatican
tout ça est du coup comme ma mère avait
des maisons en espagne
il voulait qu'il était cancéreux il
voulait mourir en espagne donc il m'a
laissé la bile là d'accord et au rejet
la cour avait organisé ses affidés rhône
profite quand on va se passer
concrètement il n'y a pas de plaintes de
voisins ah non pas les gens se doutait
de rien bah on ne faisait pas de bruit
abeilles se doutait soudoyer des stars
qui se doute puisque finalement ils ont
quand même contacté la police avait été
dénoncée bain bien sûr elle apparaît
vous sont installés dans la ville la
voisine
sur pied tout des sceaux alors là c'est
ça fait des jours comme ça au carnet en
86 quand les noms avant 86 84 80 jusqu'à
de 84 à 86 d'accord et le quai des 36
quai des orfèvres à la brigade des stups
hui vous arrête comme en 86 juliette 86
bon alors comment on peut faire encore
confiance à l'humanité après avoir vu
tant de corruption
moi je fais plus confiance à personne
allant surtout la société française je
vais vous dire mesure j'ai dans l'idée
que que ça pouvait pas être pire en 45
au niveau de ces améliorations
c'est monstrueux ce pays mais la
corruption surtout mais il ya la
corruption parler dans ce deuxième livre
d'un réseau pédophile qui est organisé
par un parc à la police oui il faut avec
des ramifications même dans saison je
vais envoyer en prison commissaire du
viiie arrondissement de paris qui
protégeait les es2 fait de tous les
livres et qui protège et enfin bref il
protégeait le n 5 français qui est en
fuite
à bangkok en thaïlande mais dans mon top
4 alors attaqué en tant que la monnaie
ou deux alors à côté - tome 32 secondes
à le tome 3 c'est une rétrospection
c'est-à-dire mangue éditeur m'a dit
quand on fait deux bouquins mais j'ai de
sa vie le troisième en explique pourquoi
on est devenu comme ça on va suivre de
veilleux le voyou devenu et c'est donc
j'explique en même temps je réponde la
vraie histoire qui m'a poussé vraiment à
devenir le méchant tout ça avec un grand
personnage marocains etc
c'est une histoire vous avez l'art
commente vous avez une sorte de mentor
oui on peut dire ça
enfin pas du bon côté de la non bah
c'est pas moi pour moi c'est le bon côté
parce que c'était au gouvernement ils
sont pire que moi pourquoi j'ai pas
honte de le dire dans une émission là il
n'ya pas longtemps j'ai dit à au
président et au mini jeu là j tiji
puisque vous êtes un gouvernement de
cocaïne aux mains je pense avoir ma
place dans ce gouvernement alléguant
donnez moi une place de minus donc est
ce que jo lernout
bon après il y aura un quatrième tome
etc qu'est ce que vous dites aux gens
qui auraient envie de prendre de la coke
vous leur dites quand même attention
c'est pas une bonne idée on est d'accord
à ce pas une bonne idée mais
certainement ce point quand
même dans ce lit au niveau essayer de de
décourager les jeunes de votre entourage
qui tenteraient dit c'est bien sûr la
fia sur une note positive relèverait pas
mais non c'est pas je dis pas que je lui
dire qu'il n'ya pas d'addiction physique
à la cocaïne il ya une diction
psychologie et puis après ça détruit bah
ça détruit regard des missions médicales
fatma bien et vous vous étiez ces
pastiches et sur laquelle j'ai beaucoup
d'amis qui sont comme moi
non parce que si on la prend et qu'on
veut et qu'on insiste et qu'on continue
à la prendre il faut prendre de la pure
il faut s'assurer qu'elle est pure et
pas encore fait à prendre enfin c'est
beaucoup trop tôt ça je le dis bien sûr
la base à la base on y touchera peut
éviter ça moi maintenant je touche plus
rien chez record du monde c'est le plus
heureux du monde vous avez réussi à
vivre une vie qui vous plaît ce sont des
mamans épaissi trépidant maintenant plus
d'alcool petit gamin je viens un coup de
drogue plus bien très bien la voilà une
bonne nouvelle
pur et dur et la vie est belle la vie
est belle mais je dis alors ceux qui
sont dedans
sortez en fasse très attention d'abord
s'ils peuvent en sortir danser mais euh
voilà
et s'ils peuvent pas en sortir qu il
fasse attention à ce qu'ils prennent
parce que oui oui oui mais on n'est pas
là pour donner un un mode d'emploi de
marbre
je vous remercie moi je dépensais bien
sûr et ben c'est d'abord merci d'une
grotte dur d'être venus écouter et ravis
de savoir que vous avez une belle vie
sans addictions et que vous allez sortir
de prochain livre donc si vous avez
envie de découvrir plein de choses qui
vous font encore une fois tombé de
l'armoire
mais hélas non merci j'ai encore et y'a
pas là bientôt un plaisir
il
[Musique]